بعد انتظار دام سنتين حصلت بلقيس على موعد
لاجراء عمليه جراحيه في القلب كان يفترض
ان تجرى وعمرها سته اشهر
قبيل اجراء العمليه يتم التاكد من حجم
الثقب في قلبها ووضعها الصحي يعود
قبل سنتين سجلنا موعدا لدى الهلال الاحمر
الافغاني لاجراء عمليه جراحيه اخيرا وصل
دورنا مسكينه بلقيس عانت كثيرا ولم نكن
نعلم ان لديها ثقبا في القلب
[موسيقى]
في غرفه العمليات ترتيبات الدقائق الاخيره
لبلقيس في احد اهم التجمعات الطبيه الخاصه
في افغانستان والهدف اغلاق فتحه كبيره بين
البطنين ضغط كبير على الفرق الطبيه جراء
خروج اكثر من نصف اطباء قلب الاطفال من
البلاد بعد انهيار النظام السابق اخيرا
تمكنت بلقيس من اجراء عمليه جراحيه في
القلب لكن هناك احد عشر الف طفل غيرها ما
زالوا ينتظرون وسط نقص في الكوادر الطبيه
وقله الامكانيات وفي ظل عقوبات امريكيه
خيبر الصديقي احد ثلاثه اطباء مختصين
بجراحه القلب ممن بقوا في افغانستان
لدينا ثلاثه وعشرون الف طفل يعانون تشوهات
خلقيه في القلب اكثر من نصفهم على قائمه
الانتظار انا وفريقي نستطيع اجراء من 35
الى 40 عمليه في الشهر اي نحو 400 عمليه
سنويا وهذا رقم ضئيل حسب بيانات وزاره
الصحه الافغانيه فقدت افغانستان بين 60
وسبعين في المئه من اطبائها المهره ليس
فقط من اطباء القلب بل من التخصصات كافه
لم يعمل النظام السابق شيئا خلال العشرين
سنه الماضيه لم يبني اي مركز صحي او
مستشفى للاطفال الذين يعانون من امراض
القلب اما نحن فافتتحنا قسما خاصا في
مستشفى الاطفال سيقدم خدماته قريبا كما ان
هناك وعودا من بعض الدول بالمساعده
فتكاليف العمليات باهظه جدا
زينب خان هي الاخرى لديها ثقبان في القلب
تنتظر دورها كالاف غيرها لاجراء عمليه
جراحيه على امل ان لا يطول الانتظار
عرفنا مشكله ابنتي وعمرها 40 يوما قالوا
لنا ان علينا دفع 4000 دولار لاجراء
العمليه بالطبع هذا مبلغ كبير جدا ولا
املكه لذلك رجعت الى الهلال الاحمر من اجل
المساعده وانا في انتظار دوري
وتشير التقارير طبيه الى ان عددا كبيرا من
الاطفال الافغان يفقدون حياتهم بسبب
التشوهات الخلقيه في القلب اذ ان نحو
25% من المصابين
يحتاجون الى عمليات جراحيه ناصر شديد
الجزيره كابل